[Music]
you can
well they said kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war
our enemy is not human and we are losing
we need you to fight
and we'll be back and i love you
chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
you won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world is it
all right
yeah going to war stop talking listen
sorry i mean when i'm nervous at talk
i'm like 97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future you and your unit
are now
in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster and stronger than you can
possibly imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous i feel like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the face of
the earth
nothing we do here matters that's where
you're wrong
i don't believe that one bit together we
can stop this war
from ever happening this is my
opportunity to give this world a second
chance
second chances are really hard to come
by
light them up
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it
in the cabin the bullet goes in thing
and everybody sucked out
[Music]
you